I did do physical therapy that's tough
it is tough when my physical therapist
enters he looks like if like Zach Efron
and like Fabio had a baby with like a
Kendall he's like this Italian like
beautiful hand therapist I don't know so
we he was talking about like respiration
and how important that is to like you
know breathe through the the physical
therapy and Ryan had come in on a red
eye and so he was sleeping in and I was
outside doing physical therapy and he
hadn't met Pierre Luigi yet Luigi
what so he's out and I just really
wanted my husband cuz I felt weird like
something was going on even though it
wasn't and how often do you have this
dream just once I'm hearing like Ryan
starting to wake up and then I hear Pier
Luigi say to me inspiration deep
inspiration oh my God and I was like
it's just my hand